[Musik]
wenn wirtschaft und ich werde jetzt das
hessen-spd ich kenne das spiel bzw
ich kenne die vorgänger bin ein großer
fan von der sp 3 und bin jetzt sehr
gespannt darauf wie der neue tage so auf
die kugel
es ist ein wunderschönes spiel muss man
echt einfach mal sagen und es los geht
es wahrscheinlich einen kampf an
rang
naja also epischen schlacht zu erinnern
bin leider gerade gestorben
es heißt ja wenn das gemetzel nicht wäre
dann wäre das screen echt gut für den
geschichtsunterricht wenn das gemetzel
nicht werden
sehen als es ist halt einfach wirklich
ein wunderschönes spiel muss man einfach
sagen
gut spielt auf jeden fall also das haben
sie großartig grad sehr viel spaß
gemacht zu spielen und viel liebe im
spiel sein das man wirklich also das
antike griechenland sehr engagieren
nachgebildet ist schwerer geworden für
die fragen im vergleich zur
vergangenheit und die steuerung ist ein
bisschen
sag mal schwierig kann allerdings auch
ein bisschen daran gelegen haben dass
wir hier nur sehr rudimentär der
klerikale und man nicht so wirklich
sehen konnte was jetzt genau wenn china
für sind müsste man dann noch mal ein
bisschen länger spielen den pessimisten
tatsächlich sagen zu können aber na ja
also ich würde erstmal sagen läuft ganz
gut im 1 litern
[Musik]